Now, when we're discussing two possible alleles. We realized
in the last exercise that we can get three
possible allele combinations. In this case two sydacines, a
sydacine and a thymine, or two thymine. We might
just say CC, CT, or TT. Now in genetics
there's a more traditional way of writing this kind
of information. Because each allele is technically on a
different chromosome. We actually separate the two alleles with
a slash. Because sometimes when we're discussing genetic information,
among geneticists. There's always the need to distinguish, okay
are we talking about information on the same chromosome,
or on different chromosomes? So as a common way of
distinguishing this, the practice arose to put a slash
here. And so that's how we are going to actually
refer to two different alleles from here on in,
in our class, C/C although I'll probably just CC. Okay
now there are two very important patterns that have just
emerged that are really important for us to define. Because
we are going to keep coming back to them throughout the
whole of the course. Although we have three possible combinations of
the alleles, there are two specific types of combinations. We
have the homozygous combination. Meaning that we have the same
alleles in the pair. So in this case we have
two cytosines or two thymines. These would be the homozygous conditions.
And we have the heterozygous combination, meaning
different alleles in the combination. So in
this case, we have one heterozygous option,
the cytosine-thymine pair. So having two alleles
allows three allelic combinations. Where two of
them are homozygous and one of them
is a heterozygous combination. But let's imagine
for a second just completely hypothetically that there
was a third allele at this same genetic
position. Where there's now a guanine or a
G instead of a cytosine or a thymine.
Of all the possible allele combinations that we
could get out of these three alleles I
want you to tell me which allelic combinations
would be considered heterozygous? Go ahead and check
any and all boxes that you think apply.